or or do you just think about this is
the opening i'm going to play i think in
an ideal world you would already have it
all mapped out you'd planned it far in
advance just like with exams but usually
chess plays they stress out about it
until the last moment at least i do and
meanwhile the game has kicked off it's
the spanish opening the roy lopez the
move is coming very very fast and we've
seen this plenty of times from magnus
carson before including during the world
championship match and during the world
championship match he was usually
bringing the black rook across one
square in this position this is what we
and there we go the rook does just
sidestep any potential pressure on the
a-line and this is what we call the
anti-marshal
it's avoiding the marshall gambit named
after the american player frank marshall
and this position arose plenty of times
in that famous clash between the pontiac
and carlson giri must have done his
homework here magnus knows pretty much
everything there is to know about this
position he actually picked up his
h-born moved at one square now he's
developing his light square bishop but i
think for players they are allowed um
other windows just to check the uh rival
games that's the only way they know how
to make decisions whether to take a draw
whether to exactly
yeah but uh usually the players they
don't do that they just focus on their
own games yeah the time control of
course is usually they won't have time
anyways when it's getting into those
critical moments all right
a few moves here yep a couple of moves
and again but it's very logical plans
from both sides white bringing the
knight out and black occupying a square
with his knight that cannot at least
temporarily get kicked away and white's
knight retreating out the way in order
to create a square for a white pawn to
kick back the black knight from his half
of the board this is still pretty
standard stuff
uh but magnus at least gaining some
space in the center some more influence
by the black pawns from my experience
here i'm never comfortable with the
black side
but then again with white sometimes the
thing is what do you do next when do you
push in the center when do you attack
the black king there's so many questions
and okay magnus he's the expert let's
trust him for now and the black queen
just sidestepping
anish it looks like he has done his
homework very well however continuing
the pace just bringing his bishop
out there maybe eyeing up that black
knight what do you think guys if you get
a chance with white will you take it
okay it's run away and the question has
been answered for us yeah retreating the
night
so um and he and he knows a niche needs
to win so he doesn't need to
push it too much yeah and meanwhile
anish does bring his bishop out maybe
trying to eliminate a key defender of
the black king the reason white has
maybe a tiny advantage in these types of
positions is because this bishop is
usually so strong we often call it the
spanish bishop because in this opening
this is the key piece if black can trade
it off or kick it back then black's
normally doing okay but right now it
sits on a great diagonal against the
black king and for example if black is a
bit
too careless and just makes a kind of
nothing move a move that doesn't improve
his position you could well see a trade
on this square and suddenly the white
knights might jump forward towards the
black king um also there's a nice hole
in the center of the board a nice
outpost potentially for white knights
later in the game
short term maybe black is okay no direct
threats but if you step back that would
allow the possibility at least of black
pushing forward and trapping the white
bishop on the edge of the board this is
always a dilemma this is one of the
things i still struggle with and trap
the bishop because it does allow
potential sacrifices and tai did tell us
that it is a must-win situation for a
niche in this game this bishop is under
fire after all anderson showed um okay
he does take oh wow i was going to say
maybe just plant it in the center of the
wood later use your knight to back it up
but he does capture on the d4 square and
surprising moves all around for me
because taken with the e pawn i mean
like
really i mean again normally
david said you got the open c file where
the queen is why why why why are you
taking this way around it's uh this is
his idea i guess he's going c4 but
really did not expect any of this and
maybe even the white knight can come out
g3 to h5 and i don't know i don't know
if i like this from black yeah it feels
like magnus is trying to be ambitious as
well and maybe that will backfire ah
meanwhile i'm surprised by every single
move in this game this one as well a bit
loose the general rule is don't touch
pawns on the side where you're weaker
and here this is where black is trying
to push black is the one initiating the
play so for white to push his pawn
forward as well
very very surprising okay he doesn't do
this i was going to say this pawn is a
potential target later on but then again
black cannot access this open file
because white's bishop stops the rook uh
using it so okay therefore magnus
decides not to clarify the tension and
he wants to trade the bishops off maybe
swing this rook across and magnus i
guess he's just not being too
materialistic he's just hoping uh hoping
that the position will open up for the
bishops
and okay meanwhile we didn't see that
happen we do see a trade instead and uh
you're playing with this knight against
the the dark square bishop that that
also seemed very promising positional
way to play but maybe not enough to win
it lock it down sit down wow it's a
little bit surprising
putting your pawns on the same kind of
squares your bishop is not supposed to
be a good idea because your bishop gets
more blocked in
but he does get a load of space over
there so i guess it's one one you know
one exchange for another but still a bit
surprising there magnus just needs a
draw
and why not uh simplify the position a
little bit and
okay here we go wow bad bishop
extraordinaire yeah
he doesn't care about his bishop he's
just got to go before he's he's done the
perfect
pattern
everything on the dark squares yeah look
at this
i mean he really he's really lucky white
doesn't have a light squared bishop
otherwise this would be disaster anish
may be a bit nervous dropping lower on
the clock than magnus and in the end
just playing an innocent pawn move okay
magnus going for a similar idea to the
one i mentioned he wants to take over on
this a file before white does so you can
just aim to target them and that's what
he's going for so he's going for eight
this pawn push and going to try to put
those you've also sprinkled your magic
dust on all the players every game today
we've seen the move h4 at some point
on that subject of h4 uh houston's after
actually tweeted us a super cool poem
about harry and i wanted to attach the
camera to a balloon i wanted to get a
little
to send him up into space
maybe one day
it would be quite good footage for the
show yeah yeah yeah it could be
a alone harry would just be a porn
you can buy you can yeah it's kind of
cheating oh but whoa we have a result
you guys
andreas penco
has won the game against levon aronian
and that must mean that esepenco
is qualified i think
quite certain but does it also mean that
levon aronian is out wow and only 20
moves lev on making a massive blunder
early in the game with white
you rarely see that but fair play to
essepenko he spotted a mistake it wasn't
obvious and he pounced to win that game
so uh meanwhile in this one still
maneuvering around black has conquered
this a file with the black rook with the
black queen but what to do with it that
is the big question white's knight
meanwhile very very stuck all the way
i'm
all the way to that dark square which is
b4 that would be that would be
phenomenal actually pretty pretty good
idea right controls that open file um
okay he's got to get this i reckon the
queens are going to try to come off and
then
you know once the coast is clear
[Laughter]
all right well the bar jumps up a little
bit for anish um
with one game finished i just wanted to
take a quick look at the live table
etipenko winning that game gaining three
points so all the other games still
going on this panko in second place and
each geary can overtake him dingley rank
can
uh go past him when he started yeah so
that'd be tremendous result incredible
performance definitely some chances um
i'm very surprised i must admit by this
king march yes it's the artistic way to
do it but black's king is not entirely
safe on this side of the board
and it does feel like white's queen is
gonna cause a lot of annoyance over the
next few turns unless black can get the
queens off i think anish might be the
one having the fun and look what white's
done he's put his pawn on b4 before the
black king can get there and uh yeah it
just feels
a bit scary now from the black side if
the white knight can somehow join the
action now
now that black doesn't control that a
file anymore now that black's king can
always be checked as it has as hat and
material it it seems like this even
whatever the computer says there's quite
a lot of danger uh for magnus in this
position because
he
he has to be very careful yeah will we
see a repetition of the position black
is offering the queen trade anish has to
decide now if you take the queens off
that will only favor black and that is
because this pawn is on a dart square
black might pick it off later in the
game so anish cannot swap queens he
wants to keep the queens on but if he
retreats with a check this is blocked if
he goes forward with the check this is
blocked and that would repeat the
position
let's go back to the players if he wants
to win okay he does keep the queens on
the board queen trade where it started
why did the queen not just put itself on
light squares earlier stopping white's
queen getting in now white's queen is in
it's all sorts of trouble for black
pester anish with that offer of queen
trade okay but then there would just be
a check and whoops not that check
this check and white's queen could
escape the trade so okay he goes for the
second plan the safer plan i don't think
you need to rush with this move you want
to prepare it first he drops his knight
back it's just torture for black it's
absolute torture because you can see
black is just
losing a move white improves losing a
move why it improves this just seems
like incredibly tough though i mean uh
you know when the knight gets this
square it's heading for white can push
at the right moment i just hate to be
black in this position
yeah fully agreed and magnus continuing
this dance with the queen's trying and
hoping praying that they come off the
board
but anish will try and keep them on if
he can
and uh he would love to keep the queen
on this diagonal if possible in order to
stop the black rook coming back down and
threatening some points do you agree
with the bar saying 1.4 advantage quite
a big advantage for a niche
i mean here in this type of position i
think we would just discuss grandmasters
we would just say it's easier to play
with white white is the one who can take
the draw at any moment if he wants black
is the one struggling and defending it's
definitely easier to play with white
okay okay but repeating the position
this is the second time we've seen this
position
okay anish needs to find a different
square for the white queen i don't think
he will take the draw i think we're safe
though i think he will oh has he's taken
a trial well nice
really what okay magnus meanwhile
smiling a niche wow bailing out with the
draw he could have kept the game going
another 20 30 moves and then gone for
the same draw yeah
you can just yeah just keep the queen
going blacks
i don't understand that at all black has
no plan i don't understand it just just
move the queen all the way back get out
the way play small yeah i mean really
really strange